the race for a vaccine intensifies as
some states gradually begin to reopen
all while new numbers continue to come
in on the number of people actually
infected by the corona virus here to
talk about the latest stats and the
ongoing White House efforts is the White
House coronavirus response coordinator
dr. deborah birx dr. Burks thanks so
much for being with us this evening
you know doctor I want to start at the
beginning because in the beginning it
was suggested that the mortality rate
would be be 5% and the numbers are so
much higher than what we have seen them
to ultimately be but the CDC never used
the complete test base to come up with a
lethality statistics in other words they
didn't use that the number of people who
would be exposed to accurately consider
the number of people who might be
affected by kovin and died from it isn't
that a little different from how the CDC
evaluated the flu because now as we test
people we know more and more people have
it and the lethality rate is so much
lower I think we're learning every day
about the virus and how it interacts
with us as human host and that's been
very important to constantly be
triangulating data I think we
underestimated very early on the number
of asymptomatic cases and I think we're
really beginning to understand that
there are people that get infected that
the symptoms are so low grade that they
don't even know that they're infected
and we're beginning to see that with the
New York studies of their cero antibody
studies so we're really beginning or and
in every other in every other country
before they had the antibody test all
they could really see are the cases that
showed up with serious symptoms and so
things are changing on a day to day
basis and dr. you know the CDC is
mandating that deaths that are affected
by kovin be attributable to Kovan so if
if the cause of death if someone is at a
hospital and say is dying of cancer or
has a hard problem if you've got doctors
or nurses wearing the same PPE equipment
who may be transferring the kovat on a
on the skin or in a nasal passage but
it's not in the blood isn't it unfair to
kind of estimate or suggest that those
deaths that aren't actually caused by
Kovan are attributable to covent if
kovat is anywhere in the in these
symptoms of the of the deceased well
this is a very complex virus and I want
to be very clear it's highly
transmissible very infectious and a lot
of people have become infected and what
we've known now from the very beginning
if you have comorbidities if you have
heart disease if you have diabetes if
you have asthma if you have cancer if
you're immunosuppressed all of those
issues make you susceptible to a much
more difficult course and still we're
seeing the majority of the people that
we're losing to this disease have those
other diseases that you just described
and so I do believe that a lot of the
diseases we're seeing in the hospital
right now yes they may have pre-existing
conditions but those pre-existing
conditions are resulting in them having
a much more serious course when they're
infected with this virus all right well
you know doctor would you agree that it
was initially thought that this was a
respiratory illness or one that
primarily affected the the the
respiratory system and thus you know out
of the gate we started talking about
ventilators and ventilators appeared to
be the problem but the written part of
the solution I should say but as we went
along would realize that you know it
affects the blood and the immune system
and the kidneys and and and so the the
thinking in the beginning that this
needed to be handled with ventilators
and finding that eighty to ninety
percent of the people who went on
ventilators ended up dying did we
approach this with the wrong methodology
should we have looked to other areas and
and did we intubate too soon well the
doctors and nurses that are on the front
line they're watching every patient very
closely and they're watching them for
what we call the oxygen level in the
blood to really ensure because that's
what you need for your brain and your
heart and your kidneys to keep
functioning and so if your oxygen level
falls too low and it cannot be kept up
with just what we call nasal canula Zoar
rebreathing oxygen mass if you can't get
enough oxygen from that then they will
intubate the patients I think it's very
important to realize that that early
report has been revised that was in JAMA
that talked about that higher level
mortality that you just mentioned and
it's very variable by age and it's very
variable by laying the time in the
hospital and so we're finding younger
people of about a 75 to 80 percent
survival rate on ventilators and so you
can't look at just one Hospital you have
to look at all the information but
certainly ventilators saved a lot of
people's lives because they were having
trouble getting oxygen into their blood
and and finally doctor is isn't it
wouldn't it be a better idea to have
those low risk individuals who are now
being isolated even if they are infected
isn't it a better idea to allow them to
go out and at least start to develop the
herd immunity that we need because
they're only going to develop the
disease in a very very mild way and
isn't the herd immunity essential to
ultimately getting rid of this virus
until at the very least we get a vaccine
well the most important way to get rid
of this virus is to get a vaccine as you
described when you we've always used the
term herd immunity when it comes to
vaccination no one would use that term
in general in discussing a pandemic and
letting a pandemic run out with this
level of Mort
quality that we see with comorbidities
we have to remember that in America we
have a lot of people even young people
with diabetes and asthma and
hypertension and so protecting them
really becomes very critical because
they can have a very difficult course
and so if we knew everybody who would do
well off right immediately that you
could really have that discussion but we
don't know who has pre-existing
conditions when we see them on the
street and that's why the president's
made it very clear that in opening up
America again there are clear gating
criteria and there are really clear
phases that every single state needs to
consider and in the bottom line of all
of this is every individual still taking
responsibility of washing their hands
not touching their face and with they
can't social distance to make sure that
they're wearing a mask because you wear
a mask to protect the other person
because when you meet them on the street
you don't know if they have a
pre-existing condition and may be
susceptible to a very difficult course
with this virus because we still have to
remember that there's sixty six sixty
seven thousand people that have
succumbed to this virus in just six to
seven weeks so when people compare it to
flu flu may have some level of mortality
but it's over weeks and months not over
six or seven weeks okay all right dr.
deborah birx thanks so much for being
with us tonight